climate Crusaders have a new Target and
it's your toilet paper The Washington
Post climate advice columnist suggests
ditching your Charmin Ultra Soft for a
bidet quote no one buys more TP than
Americans we're the country to switch to
bidets millions of trees would likely
remain standing every year the green
push doesn't end there a ban on
incandescent light bulbs is coming in
August Americans will only be able to
purchase led Alternatives which is total
makes me so mad okay let's talk about
bidets because that's what everyone
really cares about are you Pro bidet or
anti-bidet judge I'm not looking why
oh
okay I'm probably day I like the day
okay that's it that's all I'm saying
look like my dog what he's mad he goes
in a corn he won't look that's it can I
talk about the light bulbs no no
you like a bidet no I will say I'm bidet
curious
never used it I actually Googled it in
preparation for this segment how does a
bidet work it seems very messy but
here's where you've got me I will I
don't care about the whole climate thing
that that's not part of this
you can't sell me on the idea that
toilet paper gets the job done okay
there's there's the one white Charlie's
there's the dude wipes so what I'm
getting at is there's a starting point
for this conversation okay that maybe we
need to combine toilet paper and bidets
they have that's that's the thing every
okay yeah what is that uh like a baby
wipe oh but those are really they're bad
for the environment watch them I told
you I'm not in this for the environment
so I was a little worried that Greg was
not going to be here for this
conversation
you Mr Kane
Kane shoes he would be proud that you're
here I also have not used a bidet and um
unlike you I have not researched it what
do would you know how if you walked in
would you know what to do I know it
shoots water do you sit on it or do you
just Squat and hover I really don't know
the answer to that question so what do
you think you do I don't know
tell us oh I'm all of a sudden shy for
the first time I want to talk about a
have her talk how do you dry off
[Music]
you just go and and your wife uses the
same towel to dab no and this towel
isn't her dad tells and this is a
multiple youth towel no those do not
multiple use anything throw the towel
away after the death
it's her bidet she uses it more than you
do I can't use it ever that's it no I
didn't say that I said she uses it more
when do I do that don't you think that
the environmentalist will then come
after us for the towels yes and the
water oh the water what should you air
dry your
do you want to talk about the light
bulbs because I hate the light bulbs I
hate the LEDs I'm gonna go out now I'm
going to Home Depot and I'm going to buy
a case of incandescent light bulbs
because they're better for me
and I just wish that Innovation would
allow us to have the more energy
efficient light bulbs that actually are
good light bulbs yeah why do we have to
be in Europe all the time yeah
like well they started the bidets yeah
they did start the bidet they think
toilet paper is uncleanly and I'm just
saying we gotta have terrible we got a
lot to do on it I want to Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now